As for the
terrorist attack
on the Kremlin and the actual
residence of the head of state, all our
assessments were presented, almost all of my
interlocutors with whom we spoke yesterday
expressed their condemnation, in particular,
Pakistan directly condemned this
terrorist act and expressed hope
for the speedy establishment of the truth and the
identification of those responsible
This was clearly a hostile act  it is
clear that without the knowledge of the owners, the
terrorists could not have committed it, and
we will respond not by talking about
how it is or not, but by
concrete actions, I want to
say again that we have a lot of patience, there is such a
proverb, the Russians harness it for a long time Well, and so
on As for relations
Washington did not pay attention to the
statement of Tony Linkin, who said
that the United States would not dictate to Ukraine the
methods that it defends its